mark Pellegrino is an actor who's been
in such films as The Big Lebowski and
national treasure and he's been in
roughly a billion TV shows like
Supernatural Quantico Dexter lost in the
closer he's also the co-founder of the
American capitalist society mark welcome
to the show thanks for having me
did I did I pick the right shows there
you actually did yeah thank you you feel
good about that line yeah you've got a
long IMDB and yet we're not gonna talk
about acting right yeah I'm more than
all right with the thing yeah
actors talking about acting it's that's
what we get from actors got to be the
most boring boring subject matter on the
planet yeah so I'm glad we're avoiding
it all right well we're gonna go deep
into into politics and capitalism and
free speech a lot of stuff that I really
love so let's start with that
so as an actor I find that many actors
are sort of trained not to really say
what they think really share their
feelings about things especially when it
comes to politics and and opinions and
yet you're involved with the American
capitalist party yes ilysm doesn't seem
like the cool thing these days we're
into socialism yes yeah how'd you get
mixed up in cata yeah I don't know that
that must have just been a twist of fate
because I was educated in these
state-run schools to believe that
capitalism was probably the worst thing
to hit civilization since the plague and
but I grew out of that simply by
observing you know by by observing the
the prosperity that it brought so and I
see I see in in the political world
around us a market now for a free market
ideas because what I see in the
political spectrum is basically one
party with with with with two sorts of
expressions you know they both agree on
the premise of government and they
disagree on degrees yeah of that premise
but they they both agree yeah and what's
interesting about that is
I don't know that there's ever been a
better example of that than we have
right now we're assuming that it's
Clinton on the Democratic side and we
know it's gonna be Trump they're both
basically centrist short Trump says a
lot of crazy things and a lot of people
don't like things about Hillary but
they're not that different right they've
been to weddings together they've done a
lot of money things together so that
proves it more than anything else that
these parties are pretty much in bed
together and they're in bed together I
think I think the premise that they both
agree on is that it's appropriate to use
state aggression to achieve a good they
disagree on what that good is and on how
much state aggression should be applied
and in what areas but they but they
agreed that aggression is a good thing
right so okay so if you don't want the
state to be growing basically that's one
of the premises we'll talk about some of
the principles in the party then this is
a really nightmarish election right now
because this whole thing even Trump on
the Republican side for someone that
wants small government this is not a
small government Republican I don't know
there aren't many left I suppose
and certainly Bernie and and Hillary are
not small government people sack that's
kind of depressing for someone that
wants the government out of your life
right yeah I mean I don't I don't even
equate small government with good
government I equate a government that
respects individual rights and and holds
properties and viable as a good as a
good government because a small
government can be just as authoritarian
as a large government it's if its
premises are that aggression is
appropriate mm-hmm
so when did you have your sort of
political awakening you said you went to
state schools where they tell you
capitalism was bad
yet it was capitalism that was funding
these state schools because this was in
America is it yes yeah yeah so when when
did your awakening sort of happen I
think I think in my mid-20s when a
friend of mine who was in the theater
company that I belonged to introduce me
to the writings of iron Rand and at the
time I would consider myself a I would
consider myself a leftist I was the
registered Democrat and fully on the
side of statism without quite
understanding what that meant and her
writings threw me into a bit of a moral
and philosophical tailspin for
for years and it took about a decade for
me to resolve all the issues that she
that she kind of threw in my face and
made me think about yeah what do you
make of when you just say I ran I I had
your own Brooke who's the president of
the Iran yes foundation on just a couple
weeks ago a friend of mine and and a
great guy and I thoroughly enjoyed our
back-and-forth and I have to say that
probably 90% of the reaction we got to
it was positive but the 10% that well
even people that disagreed with the
specifics of how the government should
work or capitalism or you know free will
whatever it was it was all positive and
on point but the the 10% that disagreed
it wasn't there wasn't a lot based in
fact it was just screaming like horrible
you know all these awful words and all
that kind of stuff why do you think that
the philosophy of capitalism or
objectivism if we go that you know
tightly with it brings out such emotion
in people I think because it's based on
the the ethics of rational self-interest
and most people have a sort of spectrum
in their minds when they're thinking of
values and ethics and the spectrum is
you're either and and this and the
spectrum is informed by altruism
basically so that's that's the umbrella
under which everyone sees and defines
the good and to the degree that you are
selfish and and acting for your own
interests is the degree that you're
parting from the concept of altruism
which is a sacrificial ethics which says
the other should be the beneficiary of
values not you right rational
self-interest is that you should be the
beneficiary of the values that you that
you go for so okay so there's there's so
much there because that's where people
start going crazy it seems obvious to me
that if you were to do what is good for
you that doesn't mean you're going to
screw everyone else over if you were
gonna do what's good for you and in your
house well then what you do what's good
in your house is probably good for your
community it's probably good for the
wider community yes you could do all
kinds of awful things at the expense of
people but but I think this is the
disconnect people don't understand that
by doing good for yourself in a way
you're actually doing good for many
other people right is that sort of the
I think I think even though that isn't
the primary focus that is the
consequence for sure I think I think
amongst rational people there is no
conflict of interest and there is no
clash of rights in a status kind of
world that we live in then a person
going for what they want using state
aggression will will clearly do it by
gaining at the expense of somebody else
yeah
and that's sort of the the alternatives
that the the altruistic mindset gives us
you're either sacrificing yourself to
somebody else or sacrificing somebody
else to yourself and rights sort of by
nature are meant to clash yeah and I
don't think that's true in a rational
world right so we live in this time
where everyone's virtue signaling all
the time and we know what's going on on
college campuses where they're playing
this oppression Olympics thing so in a
way this is really the this is either
the antidote or at least the Codel
reverse of all of that right agreed as
opposed to just pretending that you're
for all the you're for all these groups
and then what gets lost in these groups
is the individuals and it's really about
the individual it is about the
individual it all comes down to the
individual the individual is the one who
thinks individuals one who pursues
values groups don't society doesn't
that's society and these groups are just
composed of individuals pursuing their
own ends and hopefully they're rational
and so they don't come at the expense of
somebody else yeah all right so you
started or co-founded the American
capitalist party damn what made you say
alright I'm gonna put my name out there
and I'm gonna go for something that's
that's bigger than me and and try to
change things for the better well just
I'm just not not seeing the alternatives
out there you know and and and seeing
that the parties agreed on an ethical
premise and and and so that people we're
not really seeing that there there's an
other side another argument that needs
to be brought to the fore and and for me
the fundamental question is is as I said
do you want state aggression as a means
of achieving the good or do you think
individuals pursuing their own happiness
as immoral when you say state aggression
I think some people probably think you
mean you're just you're talking about
war
or by coercion through a gun but it's
not necessarily just that right it's
initiated force against against an
individual who's committed no crime so
it it it covers the spectrum of from
from war unjust Wars all the way to the
regulatory state which in my mind is is
an act of aggression against producers
to redistribute capital in the name of
justice and so I feel like the actual
alternatives the the real alternatives
that exist in the political spectrum is
statism or Liberty and and and if you
believe that the state is an appropriate
means to achieve the good then you are
to that degree of status and if you
believe that individuals pursuing their
own happiness is a moral ideal and in no
way creates conflict then you go for
something like capitalism yeah isn't the
sad part of this that so I'm obviously
on board most of this and I want to get
into classical liberalism in a minute ok
but just as you were saying that I was
thinking you know when when we had the
primaries it's like we had those what I
think it started at 17 Republicans yeah
the only guy who touched on anything
that you just said at all was Rand Paul
who dropped out after lose either the
straw poll or the first primary I mean
that really tells you how sad our
politics are right it's distressing it
is distressing but and I think that's a
result of a couple of things
look this Trump phenomenon is is sort of
an expression of something healthy on
the one hand in that people are upset
mm-hmm they they understand that
political the PC movement is a sort of
tyranny and authoritarianism and and
irrational and they're tired of being
under its thumb and they they see how it
leads this kind of a kind of a systemic
dishonesty and and they're tired of
political elitism and they want their
their you know their notions to be
reflected in government they don't want
to be ignored and I think I think those
are very very powerful and and and true
assessments of the
I'm out there the issue though with
Trump I never thought he'd get this far
- I thought the American people would be
mad that expressed that anger but at
some point latch onto a principal and
somebody like a Rand Paul or even a
cruise you know who's sort of a
constitutional conservative would would
rise to the top your reaction right
there when you said Cruz that's sort of
how everybody felt about Cruz even the
people that liked him on the
constitutional stuff I think everybody
was kind of like just not this guy could
there be to somebody else no it's that
social agenda of conservatism that they
that they have to play to during every
election that sort of bugs me I'm sorry
it's the that's their version of the
appropriateness of using force against
people right wait let's just unpack that
a little bit so basically they would be
for all the things that you've talked
about they're for capitalism and suppose
in smaller government and states rights
and things like that and yet there's
this social component that I think you
would be completely against right so
when they're when they're getting the
government involved in who you marry and
what you smoke in your bedroom and
things of that nature that actually is
completely against what their ideology
is but they've coupled that somehow with
religion which a libertarian or a
classic liberal or a true capitalist I
suppose would be completely sure and I
don't and I don't even think they're
true representatives of capitalism as
well they're they're just as they've
been just as much a party to the fall of
the United States and to statism as the
political left has been and have never
really been very strong moral advocates
of capitalism anybody any pundit I've
heard on the right at best can say
there's no shame in the profit motive
but I've never heard them just say it's
positively good right if business works
yes actually good because you can hire
people and people can buy things and
things that nature alright so I know a
certain amount of people watching we're
only ten minutes and so are gonna say
this guy's a conservative he's a
everything he said is a conservative
that's funny I never emailed my guests
with questions in advance or anything
beforehand I did say to you something
about just a quick one line or sending
something about it's nice to have an
actor with some conservative leanings or
something because actors don't talk
about this stuff and you immediately
wrote back and said well I'm not a
conservative I'm a
SiC liberal yes now this is a phrase
that I've been talking a lot about
nobody really understands what it is
it's very close to libertarianism but
why don't you give me your definition of
what a classic liberal I will link
people to thank God and I think a
classic liberal is one that believes
that government is a monopoly of force
and that force has only one Morrow
expression in society and and that is in
a retaliatory expression so that like a
classical liberal I think believes that
you should ban the initiation of force
from all interpersonal relationships and
that that is the way that that
individual rights are preserved and the
inviolability of property is preserved
so that's my take on yeah I don't know
yeah well close I I would add I read a
great quote by Bertrand Russell we're
saying that that the classic liberal
also will change their opinions as
evidence changes not necessarily that
you're changing your moral compass but
you're willing to change as you learn
new information and we live in a time
where people just don't do that people
are afraid to change their opinions
because they're called flip-floppers or
they just get so stuck in something that
they only you know it's like on Twitter
if you only follow people that reinforce
your opinion well then then you never
chain you're in the echo chamber exactly
well I think I think it needs to be a
distinction that's made between
principle and dogma you know and
principles sort of hold for all time
they're like laws of nature the rest are
and and I yes I think liberal a liberal
especially classic liberal is is
intellectually flexible for sure but
that just speaks to the fact that
liberals are rational and and they hold
reason as a primary as opposed to any
other means of knowledge but that but
but let's not let's not push push away
the concept of principled and you know
and and believe that well if that's
easily divorce' below you know because I
think those those hold for all
time and the pragmatists that we see
today in politics who shift in
constantly at Donald Trump is a perfect
example right unprincipled pragmatist
that's sort of the opposite as an anti
intellectual kind of flexibility so I
think we want that you know that love of
reality and love of reason and that
understanding that a principle is is a
is an accumulation of fact it's it's you
know it's it's a short of a minute
mental shorthand for a lot of
information and that it holds true for
all time
yeah so that's really the the catch-22
with Trump right like we've all been
waiting desperately for someone to break
through the nonsense and one to not only
be on prompter someone to actually speak
like we speak someone to not be afraid
to share every opinion even if it's
going to upset some people and yet you
just hit on it the the sort of
underpinnings of what he's saying really
make no sense he's saying everything and
yet I've had a mildly innopolis right on
who's a big Trump supporter said that
this election just simply isn't about
policy it's just about this social it's
about that it's just about this social
component people are so sick of that
that that's purely all they're voting on
but that that's a kind of scary place to
be interested a place to be it is a
scary place to be and but understandable
as I said political correctness has is
it is a tyranny and we are seeing it in
the colleges today know how language is
being taken over by this by this
movement and and people just don't want
that anymore yeah I wish there were an
intellectual alternative to a guy like
Trump to be honest I just wish them yeah
I wish but we'll have to continue to
wish